La guerra delle Folkland
La terza guerra mondiale non è ancora scoppiata, quindi non possiamo ancora raccontarlo. La guerra delle Folkland è l'unica guerra fra due grandi paesi occidentali, capitalisti, alleati degli Stati Uniti, è l'unica guerra fra due grandi paesi occidentali che si sia combattuta dal 1945 a oggi.
E non mi sembra poco tutto sommato. È anche l'unica guerra fra due grandi paesi occidentali che io mi ricordo in vita mia e all'epoca mi aveva abbastanza impressionato e appassionato e quindi sarà anche per quello che ho deciso di raccontarla.
E poi c'è anche un altro motivo. La guerra delle Folkland, ma io sto parlando come se tutti ci ricordassimo, in tanti ci ricordiamo, la guerra dell'Inghilterra contro l'Argentina 1982.
Ecco, sono passati 32 anni. Ora la legge inglese stabilisce che dopo 30 anni i documenti vengono resi pubblici. Vengono, come si dice orribilmente adesso, desecretati, declassificati.
Insomma, l'importante è che ci sono i documenti. Poi uno va a sapere, quelli proprio segreti e un po' brutti probabilmente li fanno sparire lo stesso.
Ma di fatto due anni fa il governo inglese ha messo a disposizione una marea di documenti riservati o segreti.
Insomma, sopra c'è scritto top secret comunque. E adesso sono tutti in rete, sono tutti online.
Si trovano, c'è un sito fantastico, bisogna masticare l'inglese, della fondazione Margaret Thatcher, dove trovi questa marea di documenti, la trascrizione delle telefonate con Reagan, gli appunti, gli commenti sul telegramma, i verbali della riunione di gabinetto.
Ecco, un'infinità di cose che uno vorrebbe avere, tutto sommato, i verbali delle riunioni ministeriali confidenziali, non dico di Obama o di Putin, magari anche di Renzi oggi, tutto sommato, sapere cosa si dicono quando sono proprio in privato.
Fra trent'anni forse lo sapremo. In ogni caso sappiamo cosa si dicevano nell'82 e questo è forse il motivo principale per cui a me è venuta voglia di andare a vedere com'è che è scoppiata quella guerra.
Che chiamo la guerra delle folkland perché bisogna comunque scegliere. È un po' triste perché già decidere di chiamarle la guerra delle folkland significa già un po' schierarsi.
Lo sapete, gli inglesi le chiamano le folkland, gli argentini le chiamano le malvinas e decidere di chiamarle in un certo modo vuol dire già prendere posizione.
Io, vabbè, ufficialmente si chiamavano le folkland all'epoca e si chiamano le folkland oggi, però, come dire, non nego, non nego che secondo me, no, secondo me, diciamo, io nei confronti di quella guerra trovo che gli inglesi non avevano tutti i torti, ecco, tutto sommato.
E quindi non mi dispiace troppo chiamarla la guerra delle folkland.
Allora, per capire, provare a capire, a raccontare com'è che è scoppiata quella guerra, in realtà la cosa principale è sapere che cosa sono le folkland,
che è più di quello che sapeva la maggioranza degli inglesi a quell'epoca.
Se hanno ragione quei giornalisti inglesi che hanno scritto, all'epoca, la grande maggioranza del popolo britannico pensava che le folkland fossero delle isole da qualche parte al largo della Scozia.
In effetti le folkland sono un arcipelago abbastanza grande, tutte insieme sono a metà della Sicilia.
Sono un arcipelago sperduto nell'Atlantico meridionale, molto a sud, verso l'Antartico, e il posto più vicino è l'Argentina.
Le folkland sono a 500 chilometri dalla costa argentina e sono abitate da una popolazione di origine inglese e scozzese, che parla inglese, che ha la cittadinanza britannica
e questo stato di cose dura, durava, adesso non fatemi fare il calcolo, ma all'epoca di cui parlo erano 150 anni giusti.
Nel 1833 la flotta di sua maestà britannica prende possesso delle folkland.
Quindi nel 1983 era previsto il centocinquantesimo anniversario.
Voi sapete che i centocinquantesimi anniversari sono cose serie, che creano poi discussioni, fanno pensare e così via.
Dunque, in Argentina, non tanto in Inghilterra, voi mi scuserete, io dirò spesso Inghilterra invece di dire Gran Bretagna, è l'abitudine nostra italiana,
non tanto in Inghilterra dove appunto la gente pensava che fossero delle isolette scozzesi come le Orcadi e le Shetland,
ma in Argentina l'avvicinarsi di questo anniversario, 150 anni di occupazione inglese delle Malvinas,
in Argentina faceva pensare e faceva discutere.
Perché l'altra cosa da sapere per capire quello che vi racconterò stasera
è che in Argentina le Malvinas sono un mito popolare.
In Argentina da 150 anni si insegna agli scolaretti che i cattivi colonizzatori imperialisti inglesi hanno occupato le Malvinas
e un giorno dovranno risputarle fuori perché le Folkland sono argentine, las Malvinas son argentinas.
Questa cosa in Argentina la sanno tutti, l'hanno sentita tutti fin da quando erano bambini
e come Trento e Trieste in Italia al tempo della Prima Guerra Mondiale.
Magari se volete con questa piccola differenza che a Trento e Trieste effettivamente erano italiani gli abitanti,
mentre le Folkland sono inglesi.
Ma qui è una questione di territorio.
Allora, la decisione di fare qualcosa prima che arrivi questo benedetto 150esimo anniversario
la prende la gente che comanda in Argentina in quel momento.
La decisione l'hanno presa, oggi lo sappiamo, nel dicembre 1981.
Chi è la gente che comanda in Argentina in quel momento?
Non ci mettiamo niente a ricordarcelo.
Quella è l'Argentina dei generali.
È la dittatura dei generali.
Non c'è bisogno che venga io a dirvi che è stata una delle più sanguinose dittature del Novecento.
La dittatura della guerra sporca, come dicevano loro, la guerra suzia contro i comunisti, i terroristi, la sinistra in generale.
La dittatura dei desaparecidos.
Ancora oggi si discute quanti, ma comunque decine di migliaia fatti sparire da questa giunta militare.
Ora, nel dicembre, nel corso dell'81, la giunta militare è a un bivio, perché la situazione in Argentina è catastrofica.
E la popolarità della dittatura militare è ai livelli più bassi.
La situazione in Argentina è catastrofica per molti motivi.
Intanto è catastrofica dal punto di vista economico.
L'inflazione è al 600%.
La povertà è diffusa.
Nonostante la dittatura militare, i sindacati sono in piazza tutti i giorni a protestare.
Nonostante il fatto che ogni manifestazione viene repressa dalla polizia.
E alla crisi economica si accoppia alla crisi politica.
Sta venendo fuori il problema dei desaparecidos.
Ci sono le madri di Piazza di Maggio, che oggi sono diventate le nonne, se ci sono ancora, di Plaza de Maio,
che ogni giovedì manifestano davanti alla Casa Rosada, al Palazzo Presidenziale a Buenos Aires,
a chiedere dove sono finiti i nostri figli.
E anche quelle manifestazioni vengono represse dalla polizia, disperse, e ogni giovedì sono di nuovo lì.
Quindi, in sostanza, l'Argentina è in ebollizione.
La giunta militare traballa e non sa più che pesci prendere.
Tant'è vero che la giunta militare, alla fine del 1981, si fa il golpe da sola.
Il dittatore che c'era fino a quel momento, il generale Viola, viene deposto da un altro generale,
che col consenso della maggioranza dei militari prende il potere.
Quest'altro generale si chiama Leopoldo Galtieri.
Il generale Galtieri, il 22 dicembre dell'81, prende il potere in Argentina,
si proclama presidente a vita dell'Argentina,
con poteri assoluti e con la facoltà di scegliersi un successore.
Allora, chi è, breve profilo, chi è il generale Galtieri?
Galtieri. Come gran parte degli argentini è figlio di poverissimi immigranti italiani.
Sapete che l'Argentina è un paese mezzo italiano.
Metà degli argentini hanno almeno un antenato italiano.
Il generale Galtieri è un militare di origine italiana che ha fatto carriera.
Come ha fatto carriera Leopoldo Galtieri?
C'è un episodio cruciale nella sua carriera militare.
Nel 1949, giovane tenente, viene scelto per seguire un corso in una scuola particolare.
A Panama c'è una scuola gestita dall'esercito degli Stati Uniti
per ufficiali degli eserciti sudamericani.
School of the Americas.
Questa scuola delle Americhe a Panama è una scuola dove i giovani ufficiali degli eserciti
cileno, brasiliano, argentino, peruviano, colombiano
vengono istruiti da istruttori statunitensi
da quello che sembra di capire non tanto a fare la guerra quanto a fare la repressione,
a fare la controguerriglia.
Molti dittatori e collaboratori di dittatori sudamericani
passano attraverso questa scuola a Panama.
Ci passa anche il sottotenente Leopoldo Galtieri dell'esercito argentino.
Qui vi dico un pettegolezzo, ma secondo me è un pettegolezzo.
Quando è morto Galtieri una decina di anni fa
il giornale inglese The Economist ha pubblicato un necrologio perfido
in cui fra l'altro dice
a quanto risulta Galtieri è l'unico ufficiale nella storia
che è stato bocciato alla scuola di Panama per ufficiali sudamericani.
Ma questo, ripeto, secondo me è un pettegolezzo dell'economist, non è detto che sia vero.
Fatto sta che Galtieri fa carriera
e quando la giunta militare prende il potere in Argentina
Galtieri è uno dei personaggi di spicco
ed è uno dei personaggi più visibili anche a livello internazionale.
All'inizio dell'81, il colpo di Stato lo fa a dicembre
diventa presidente a vita
dieci mesi prima era stato negli Stati Uniti
ricevuto da Ronald Reagan, presidente degli Stati Uniti
con baci e abbracci
gli Stati Uniti sono amici dell'Argentina
specialmente da quando l'Argentina fa questa politica di feroce anticomunismo
e stronca l'opposizione di sinistra all'interno
Reagan vede nel regime dei generali e lo dichiara apertamente
un baluardo dell'anticomunismo
se qualcuno di voi c'era ieri a me viene un déjà vu
ricordate Lord Halifax, il ministro degli esteri inglese
che nel 37 va a Berlino e dice a Hitler
certo la Germania, baluardo dell'anticomunismo
ecco vabbè la storia ogni tanto si ripete a modo suo
il generale Galtieri a Washington viene ricevuto con entusiasmo
ci sono varie dichiarazioni su quanto è bravo questo generale argentino
un magnifico generale dichiara
non si sa più quale consigliere di Reagan
ci sono versioni diverse ma insomma un magnifico generale
nel dicembre di quello stesso anno 81
il magnifico generale fa il colpo di Stato
prende il potere in Argentina
col sostegno degli ammiragli e dei generali
con cui si è messo d'accordo
faremo una cosa che metterà tutto a posto
occuperemo le Falkland
anzi le Malvinas
occuperemo le Malvinas
il patto che porta al potere Galtieri
prevede che nei prossimi mesi
si progetta questa occupazione
con la forza delle Malvinas
sulla base
io in queste serie vi ho sempre parlato di scommesse
anche qua ci sono due scommesse
la prima scommessa è che il popolo argentino
alla notizia che sono state occupate le Malvinas
occupate, liberate le Malvinas
sarà folle di entusiasmo
pazzo di delirio patriottico
e si dimenticherà l'inflazione
i desaparecidos e così via
prima scommessa vanno vicini a vincerla
perché per qualche giorno effettivamente
in Argentina succederà esattamente questo
la seconda scommessa è che il mondo
accetterà il fatto compiuto
gli inglesi non avranno mai il coraggio di reagire
e in ogni caso il presidente Reagan
è amico nostro
e di conseguenza farà in modo
che non ci siano gravi problemi
la decisione dei militari argentini
ovviamente all'inizio è segreta
non trappela niente
anche perché in realtà da un po' di anni
l'impressione è che la questione delle Folkland Malvinas
si stia abbastanza risolvendo
dovete sapere che da una quindicina d'anni
ci sono ogni tanto degli incontri
anglo-argentini
in cui si discute sul futuro delle Folkland
e in questi incontri si va avanti
si fanno degli accordi
la Gran Bretagna non ha mai messo sul piatto
la sovranità sulle isole
però la sensazione diffusa
è che un giorno magari se ne potrà anche parlare
si accettano forme di cogestione
anche l'Argentina fa delle grosse concessioni
per intenderci
l'Argentina in quegli anni
visto che si sta negoziando
e trattando in un clima cordiale
garantisce i collegamenti aerei e navali
con le Folkland
che altrimenti sarebbero completamente isolate
perché l'Argentina è a 500 chilometri
ma qualunque altro posto al mondo
è a migliaia di chilometri dalle Folkland
quindi c'è un clima cordiale
l'ultima riunione
questi incontri si fanno a New York
perché è l'ONU
che ha costretto gli inglesi e gli argentini
a negoziare
si incontrano a New York
l'ultima riunione è stata nel febbraio dell'82
a fine febbraio dell'82
c'è ancora un incontro
e il comunicato finale
sapete che negli incontri diplomatici
è fondamentale poi
il linguaggio del comunicato stampa alla fine
da cui si capisce come è andata
il comunicato finale dice
l'incontro è stato cordiale e amichevole
questo a fine febbraio
il 2 marzo
esce una dichiarazione del governo argentino
il governo argentino dichiara
l'argentina ha negoziato con la Gran Bretagna
sul problema della sovranità delle isole
con pazienza, lealtà e buona fede
per più di 15 anni
adesso basta
adesso gli argentini dicono
basta incontri così decisi di volta in volta
noi vogliamo
oggi si direbbe una road map
allora non lo dicevano ancora nell'82
noi vogliamo una scadenza precisa
una scaletta di incontri mensili
allo scopo di trasferire all'argentina
la sovranità sulle isole
l'Inghilterra deve dirci
entro quando
trasferirà la sovranità
il comunicato si conclude così
se questo non sarà accettato
l'argentina intende mettere fine ai negoziati
e scegliere liberamente la procedura
che conviene di più ai suoi interessi
il linguaggio diplomatico è sempre così delicato
però se uno legge fra le righe
il comunicato è del 2 marzo
il 3 marzo la stampa argentina perde la testa
i giornali di Buenos Aires impazzano
prevedono la rottura dei rapporti diplomatici con l'Inghilterra
potremmo anche tagliare le comunicazioni alle Folkland
come fanno senza noi che con gli nostri aerei
gli portiamo le medicine, i rifornimenti
la stampa argentina dice
l'Inghilterra
ecco la stampa argentina dice una cosa
che il governo argentino non ha detto
il governo argentino ha detto
bisogna che fissiamo una data
la stampa va più in là
l'Inghilterra ha 3 o 4 mesi di tempo
per riconoscere la sovranità argentina
sulle isole e fissare la data della restituzione
se no la stampa dice quello che il governo non ha detto
potremmo anche riprendercele le isole
gli americani capirebbero
l'ambasciatore inglese a Buenos Aires
quel mattino si prende tutti i giornali
trascrive i titoli e gli articoli
manda un telegramma a Londra al primo ministro
sulla sua copia di questo telegramma
il primo ministro a Londra annota
we must make contingency plans
dobbiamo fare dei piani nel caso che
è il 3 marzo dell'82
l'arrivo di questa notizia a Londra
è un fulmine a ciel sereno
nessuno si aspettava niente
questa storia è anche in parte
una storia di fallimenti
dell'intelligence, della diplomazia
il ministero degli esteri inglese
non ha previsto nulla
un giornalista inglese l'ha spiegato
dice
il foreign office
il ministero degli esteri inglese
è strapieno di arabisti
che sono sempre pronti ad andare a mettere le cose a posto nel Medio Oriente
invece non c'è praticamente nessuno
a nessun livello
che conosca il Sud America
o a cui gliene importi qualcosa
quindi il foreign office
tutto pensava
meno che gli argentini
entrassero in crisi per le Falkland
i servizi segreti
non solo hanno rassicurato
ma per tutto il mese di marzo
continueranno a rassicurare il primo ministro
sì gli argentini
si sa che gente sono
sono mezzi italiani
parlano
ma non faranno mai niente
noi li abbiamo i rapporti
ormai
quindi è storia documentata
l'intelligent service di sua maestà 007
è convinto che gli argentini bluffano
il primo ministro è un po' inquieto lo stesso
il primo ministro inglese naturalmente è la signora Thatcher
Margaret Thatcher
la prima donna
di cui mi capita di parlare in queste nostre elezioni
la prima donna di cui mi capita di dire
andiamo a vedere come si comporta a gestire una crisi
sarebbe troppo facile dire
vediamo se si comporta diversamente
beh lasciamo perdere
ecco
tenete conto solo di questo
stavolta per la prima volta nella storia
forse dal tempo della regina Elisabetta
nel Cinquecento
è una donna
che deciderà se la guerra si deve fare oppure no
però attenzione
perché Margaret Thatcher
che è morta l'anno scorso
ormai ha concluso la sua carriera
e la sua vita
è passata alla storia
è un personaggio storico di grandissimo rilievo
che ha inciso sul mondo
perché le riforme della Thatcher
le liberalizzazioni
la lotta contro i sindacati
la distruzione del potere dei sindacati
la fine delle nazionali
le privatizzazioni
il Thatcherismo
ha cambiato il mondo davvero
ognuno in cuor suo
e anche ufficialmente e apertamente
sa se dobbiamo essere contenti oppure no
di come la signora Thatcher ha cambiato il mondo
però certamente per noi
è un personaggio di enorme rilievo
nella primavera del 1982
la signora Thatcher non è ancora
quella che è passata alla storia
non ha ancora vinto nessuno delle sue battaglie
l'Inghilterra è in crisi economica
la Thatcher non ha sconfitto i sindacati
non ha privatizzato
non è riuscita a fare niente
e per di più è schiacciata
come era anche il governo inglese nel 1914
peraltro
da questa enorme piaga
che l'Inghilterra si porta dietro
che è l'Irlanda
quando esplode la crisi con l'Argentina
per le Falkland
sono passati pochi mesi
da una vicenda che tutti noi ci ricordiamo
quando i detenuti nordirlandesi dell'Ira
cominciano a fare lo sciopero della fame
ricordate Bobby Sands
per avere condizioni migliori
essere riconosciuti come prigionieri politici
e si lasciano morire di fame
uno dopo l'altro
in dieci muoiono di fame
chiedendo al governo inglese
di riconoscerli come prigionieri politici
e il governo inglese
cioè Margaret Thatcher
dice no
un reato è un reato
è un reato
la politica non c'entra niente
firmato Margaret Thatcher
allora la Thatcher in quel momento è debolissima
non ha ancora fatto niente
e tutti prevedono che perderà le prossime elezioni
fra tante cose che deve pensare
arrivano anche questi rapporti
che i giornali di Buenos Aires
impazzano per le isole Falkland
ma i servizi segreti dicono di non preoccuparsi
la signora Falkland
la signora Falkland addio
la signora Thatcher aspetta
gli argentini nel corso del mese di marzo
cominciano a trafficare nella zona
per far salire comunque la tensione
allora qui vi devo raccontare una cosa
mi ero detto la racconto
no lasciamola fuori
no però c'è
perché marzo succede solo questo
che sto per dirvi adesso
allora
vicino alle isole Falkland
c'è un altro arcipelago
ancora più disgraziato
ancora più freddo
dove non ci abita nessuno
solo pinguini
si chiama la Georgia del Sud
appartiene alla corona britannica
c'è soltanto un plotone di Marines
con una stazione di rilevamento
così meteorologico
quando dico che le isole della Georgia del Sud
sono vicine alle Falkland
voi vi metterete a ridere
sono a 2000 km dalle Falkland
ma sono il pezzetto di terra emersa
più vicino comunque
intorno non c'è niente
andate a casa guardate la cartina
il vuoto cosmico
quindi la Georgia del Sud e le Falkland
appartengono a una stessa zona
strategica
in queste isole della Georgia del Sud
nel corso del mese di marzo
cominciano a succedere cose strane
sbarcano degli argentini
sono dei gruppetti di operai
c'è un contratto per un recupero di metalli
però questi operai argentini
a un certo punto
innalzano la bandiera argentina
i Marines di Guardia
non sanno bene cosa fare
in realtà noi oggi sappiamo
che questi operai argentini
in parte sono commandos dell'esercito
giusto un dettaglio
per ricordarci l'epoca
non sarebbe necessario
ma ve lo somministro lo stesso
il comandante di questo gruppo di Marines argentini
travestiti da operai
che sbarca nel marzo dell'82
nelle isole della Georgia del Sud
è un ufficiale
che si chiama il tenente Alfredo Astif
che attualmente se ne sta
all'ergastolo in Argentina
noto per essere
uno dei principali torturatori
attivi in quello che era
il principale centro di tortura
a Buenos Aires
la scuola di meccanica dell'armada
la scuola di meccanica della Marina
il tenente Alfredo Astif
nel marzo dell'82
sospende momentaneamente
la sua attività
al centro torture della Marina
per andare a sbarcare
nelle isole della Georgia del Sud
giusto per chiudere appunto
è all'ergastolo ma da pochi anni
prima l'hanno condannato all'ergastolo
i francesi ma in contumacia
perché fra le molte persone
che ha torturato e ucciso
Alfredo Astif
c'erano anche due suore francesi
poi finalmente tre anni fa
anche gli argentini
l'hanno mandato all'ergastolo
con chiusa parentesi
succede tutto questo
e a Londra si dicono
ma che cosa vogliono gli argentini
i servizi segreti dicono
eh sono preoccupati
le Folk
ma nessun pericolo
prima che decidano di sbarcare
la Thatcher
pensa di negoziare
offrire un negoziato
vedere cosa dicono
non se ne occupa
neanche tanto lei
se ne occupa
il ministro degli esteri
inglese
oh
apriamo una piccola parentesi
il ministro degli esteri
inglese
è
Lord Carrington
che poi qualcuno ricorderà
perché è stato anche
segretario generale
della Nato
Lord Carrington
Peter Carrington
è un ministro
molto fedele
alla Thatcher
un grande amico
è uno che sente molto
il carisma
è uno dei primi
che hanno riconosciuto
nella Thatcher
un personaggio
formidabile
c'è l'aneddoto
famoso
in Inghilterra
di un giornalista
che intervista
Lord Carrington
e siccome
la Thatcher
sembra molto debole
e tutti sono convinti
che alle prossime elezioni
la Thatcher salta
il giornalista
vuol far dire
a Lord Carrington
suo ministro degli esteri
dice
ma se salta
la Thatcher
il partito conservatore
chi mette
al suo posto
e Lord Carrington
non vuole dirlo
dice no no
resta lei
non si discute
il giornalista
alla fine
spazientito
dice va bene
ma supponiamo
che domani
un autobus
investa
la signora Thatcher
e Lord Carrington
risponde
l'autobus
non avrebbe
il coraggio
di farlo
dunque
Lord Carrington
è un uomo
di fiducia
per Margaret
e il ministero
degli esteri
garantisce
che problemi
non ce ne dovrebbero essere
il primo giorno
in cui il ministero
degli esteri
guidato da Lord Carrington
comincia a preoccuparsi
è il 24 marzo
quel giorno
Lord Carrington
manda un appunto
al primo ministro
e dice
noi stiamo discutendo
se si può negoziare
con gli argentini
ma guarda che il clima
è pazzesco
la loro stampa
continua a insultarci
io non so
se possiamo negoziare
con qualcuno
che appunto
ci insulta
ci fa pressione
in questo modo
potrebbe anche darsi
che si dovesse arrivare
a un confronto
cosa vorrà dire
arrivare a un confronto
però intanto
il primo ministro
è avvertito
effettivamente
Lord Carrington
è arrivato appena in tempo
è il 24 marzo
noi sappiamo oggi
che il 26 marzo
Galtieri
presidente a vita
dell'Argentina
dà il via
all'invasione
delle Falkland
operazione
Rosario
piano di sbarco
nelle Malvinas
per il 2 aprile
nessuno lo sa
è segretissimo
la Thatcher
si è resa conto
che la tensione
sta montando
cosa facciamo
cosa si fa
quando la tensione
monta
da un lato
magari
continua a dire
ma negoziamo
eh sì
però fin quando
continua a dire
noi siamo disposti
a negoziare
viene il momento
in cui devi dire
però guardate
che noi facciamo
sul serio
il 29 marzo
la signora Thatcher
fa quello che può fare
dà ordine
di far partire
immediatamente
un sottomarino nucleare
da Gibilterra
per le Falkland
il sottomarino nucleare
ci metterà due settimane
per arrivare
alle Falkland
ma intanto
la notizia
trapela
alla stampa
non si sa come
la signora Thatcher
è molto soddisfatta
che la stampa
l'abbia saputo
nelle sue memorie
dirà
il mio istinto
era
che era venuto
il momento
di far vedere
agli argentini
come tradurre
in inglese dice
that we meant business
che facevamo
sul serio
insomma
viene il momento
in cui bisogna
mostrare i muscoli
anche noi
vi ricorda le cose
che abbiamo raccontato
ieri sera
l'altro ieri sera
sì anche a me
me le ricorda
per fortuna
è tutto molto più in piccolo
ma
signora Thatcher
è preoccupata
nonostante
le garanzie
del ministero degli esteri
dei servizi segreti
lei annota
no veramente
questo non lo annota
lo scrive nelle memorie
a cose fatte
quindi prendetela
con beneficio di inventario
perché nelle memorie
uno magari poi
un po' è giusta
però nelle memorie
la Thatcher dice
ero preoccupata
perché tutti mi garantivano
che gli argentini
non avrebbero invaso
ma
sapevamo che erano
gente imprevedibile
e instabile
lì non si sa
se intende dire
questi dittatori
oppure questi latini
si sa che
e che una dittatura
non sempre si comporta
in modi
che noi considereremmo
ragionevoli
perciò
ero molto incerta
dice la Thatcher
in seguito
e ricordando
ma penso
che nessuno
di noi
si aspettasse
davvero
l'invasione
delle Falkland
la cosa
precipita
la sera
del 31 marzo
il ministro
della difesa
inglese
John Knott
chiede
alla Thatcher
una riunione
d'urgenza
convocano
qualche ministro
il ministro
della difesa
si precipita
a Downing Street
con un rapporto
dei servizi segreti
americani
che finalmente
hanno aiutato
gli inglesi
a capirci qualcosa
i servizi segreti
americani
hanno notizie
sicurissime
quella sera
del 31 marzo
la flotta
argentina
è in mare
carica di truppe
e fa rotta
verso le Falkland
questa riunione
della sera
del 31 marzo
è uno dei momenti
decisivi
naturalmente
il ministro
della difesa
inglese
espone la situazione
e dichiara
alla signora
Thatcher
che se gli argentini
occupano le isole
è impensabile
pensare di riprenderle
non potremmo
mai farcela
alla Thatcher
si rizzano i cappelli
in testa
come non potremmo
mai farcela
è del tutto
escluso
noi le dobbiamo
riprendere
se loro
sbarcano
e non mi venire
a dire che non
lo possiamo fare
dove sono i militari
dove è l'ammiraglio
capo di stato maggiore
della flotta
non è ancora arrivato
l'ammiraglio
capo di stato maggiore
della flotta
com'è che non arriva
Sir Henry Leach
capo di stato maggiore
della flotta
di sua maestà
non arriva
alla riunione
finalmente lo scoprono
era in borghese
ha pensato di tagliar corto
attraversando il Parlamento
l'hanno arrestato
mentre attraversava il Parlamento
vestito in borghese
finalmente un deputato
l'ha riconosciuto
dice ma è l'ammiraglio
allora l'hanno portato
dal primo ministro
il primo ministro
chiede all'ammiraglio
è pensabile
montare una spedizione
per riprendere
le Falkland
se quelli sbarcano
l'ammiraglio
fa due conti
e le dice
certo che si può
posso mandare
questa portaerei
quell'altra
cacciatore pedinieri
fregate
ce l'ho
quello ce l'ho
o tutto
se date l'ordine
comincio a riunire
la flotta
chi è che può dare
l'ordine
ci vuole un voto
del Parlamento
vanno a vedere
no lo può dare
il primo ministro
non è la guerra
è solo riunire la flotta
quella sera
il primo ministro
ordina all'ammiraglio
di cominciare
a riunire la flotta
e dicono
vabbè
poi l'ordine di partenza
sarà meglio
parlarne in consiglio
dei ministri
magari
ma prima
è il 31 marzo
lo sbarco argentino
è previsto
per il 2 aprile
c'è ancora un giorno e mezzo
un giorno
due notti
bisogna assolutamente
fare qualcosa
per vedere
se si riesce a fermarli
cosa si fa
il sottomarino nucleare
l'abbiamo già mandato
quindi vabbè
come si fa
per fermarli
c'è un unico modo
nel mondo
post seconda guerra mondiale
cosa avreste fatto voi
telefono al grande fratello
telefono a Ronald Reagan
la Thatcher
manda
non telefono
manda un telegramma
sulla linea riservata
a Reagan
con urgenza
vi leggo il telegramma
della Thatcher
a Reagan
notte del 31 marzo
caro Ron
sarai al corrente
delle informazioni
inquietanti
dei nostri
e vostri
servizi segreti
per cui la marina
argentina
si starebbe preparando
a invadere
le Falkland
entro 48 ore
e fra le altre cose
puoi parlare
urgentemente
al presidente argentino
e chiedergli
di non autorizzare
alcuno sbarco
tanti cari saluti
Margaret
allora entra in campo
un nuovo giocatore
gli Stati Uniti d'America
la Casa Bianca
entra in campo
Reagan
telefona a Galtieri
Galtieri
non si fa trovare
anche questa
l'abbiamo già sentita
finalmente
Reagan insiste
dopo un po'
è difficile dirgli di no
ti telefono
al presidente
degli Stati Uniti
dopo un po'
Galtieri risponde
noi abbiamo
una fonte
in presa diretta
è il diario
di un collaboratore
di Reagan
si chiama
Jim Rentschler
è il funzionario
della Casa Bianca
che è stato incaricato
di informare
Reagan
di questa faccenda
di cosa sono le Falkland
di cosa sta succedendo
perché deve telefonare
a questo Galtieri
il funzionario
della Casa Bianca
Jim Rentschler
mentre Reagan
è al telefono
con Galtieri
butta giù
qualche appunto
per il suo diario
è uno furbetto
che ha già capito
che il diario
sarà importante
quindi è locura
è fatto bene
il diario
il diario di Rentschler
mentre Reagan
è lì al telefono
Rentschler annota
comincia con una battuta
sulla pubblicità
della Bell Company
la compagnia telefonica
americana
c'è questa pubblicità
che dice tipo
basta allungare la mano
e Rentschler scrive
la Bell Company
non ha avuto mai
a che fare
col generale
Leopoldo Galtieri
e poi spiega
principale collaboratore
di Reagan
è l'uomo forte
argentino
con cui
il presidente
è al telefono
sulla linea
a lunga distanza
con Buenos Aires
in questo momento
per convincerlo
a rinunciare
a invadere
le isole
Falkland
mai sentite
vero?
neanch'io
fino a ieri sera
questo è l'uomo
che ha istruito
la pratica
per Ronald Reagan
neanch'io
fino a ieri sera
quando è arrivata
questa richiesta
del primo ministro inglese
di impedire
agli argentini
di sbarcare
in queste isole
Falkland
poi c'è un giudizio
su Galtieri
tenete conto
Galtieri è l'uomo
che un anno prima
è stato accolto
a braccia aperte
a Washington
un magnifico generale
adesso il consigliere
di Reagan
sta ascoltando
la telefonata
e annota
questo tizio
Galtieri
che non sta
a aspettare
l'interprete
parla per primo
in una specie
di inglese
da boss mafioso
voi capite
potrebbe essere
un italiano
un argentino
l'inglese lo sa
così così
e a loro
cosa evoca
tanti sceneggiati
hanno visto
col mafioso
che parla
con l'accento latino
questo Galtieri
che parla
in questa
broken english
in questa specie
di inglese
da boss mafioso
ha l'aria
di un bandito
e Renshler
annota
il presidente
sta parlando
con grande eloquenza
lo ammiro molto
ma mi sa
che il macismo
di questi argentini
gli impedirà
di fermarsi
macismo
ormai
hanno deciso
e non possono
perdere la faccia
andranno avanti
Reagan
povero uomo
fa quello
che può
Reagan è uno
che a quanto poi
si viene a scoprire
in quei giorni
dichiara
uno dei suoi assistenti
ma io non capisco
perché litigano
tanto
per quel
mucchietto
di terra
gelida
laggiù
in fondo
ice cold
bunch of land
down there
però
Reagan
una cosa
ce l'ha
quando bisogna
prendere una posizione
si butta
e la prende
voi sapete
perché ve l'ho detto
che gli argentini
hanno fatto un calcolo
preciso
noi siamo amiconi
degli americani
gli americani
non interverranno
e faranno in modo
che nessuno intervenga
Reagan
quella sera
discute con i suoi consiglieri
c'è qualcuno
che gli dice
sì effettivamente
lasciali fare
gli argentini
sono amici nostri
io non so se vi ricordate
quel politico
donna anche lei
americano
che si chiamava
Jean Kirkpatrick
la signora Kirkpatrick
ambasciatore degli Stati Uniti
all'ONU
e così via
la quale era famosa
la signora Kirkpatrick
perché nei confronti
delle dittature
diceva
le dittature
sono tutte
una brutta cosa
ma ci sono i regimi
recuperabili
e quelli non recuperabili
quelli non recuperabili
sono i regimi di sinistra
con quelli
non si può fare niente
le dittature di destra
sono recuperabili
e di conseguenza
con loro
si può anche
andare d'accordo
la signora Kirkpatrick
sarebbe
per non fare niente
l'America si tiene fuori
che facessero loro
nota di colore
il giorno dopo
la signora Kirkpatrick
sarà ospite d'onore
a un pranzo
all'ambasciata argentina
ma l'altro consigliere
Douglas Haig
il segretario di Stato
di Reagan
è dell'opinione contraria
non possiamo
lasciarli andare avanti
e Reagan
accetta
e si piega
e scrive
alla cara Margaret
telegramma di Reagan
cara Margaret
ho appena parlato a lungo
col generale Galtieri
sulla situazione
nelle Falkland
gli ho trasmesso
la mia preoccupazione
personale
sulla possibilità
di un'invasione argentina
gli ho detto
che cominciare
le operazioni militari
comprometterebbe
offerte in buoni uffici
eccetera eccetera
eccetera
il generale
mi ha ascoltato
ma non ha preso
nessun impegno
anzi
mi ha lasciato
con la chiara impressione
che ormai
si sono imbarcati
nel conflitto armato
e Reagan
conclude il telegramma
alla Thatcher
mentre la nostra politica
sulla questione
della sovranità
delle Falkland
è di neutralità
non saremo
neutrali
nel caso
che l'Argentina
usi la forza militare
tante buone cose
wrong
la Thatcher
riceve questo telegramma
da cui viene fuori
che gli argentini
ormai non si fermano più
e che gli americani
non li coprono
che se gli argentini
usano davvero la forza
gli americani
staranno con noi
a questo punto
la Thatcher
riunisce il governo
la mattina del 2 aprile
gli argentini
sono già sbarcati
alle Falkland
non lo sanno ancora
l'ambasciatore
delle Falkland
ha mandato un messaggio
si è perso nell'aere
non è mai arrivato
arriverà poi più tardi
un messaggio
di un radio amatore
delle Falkland
che viene intercettato
da un bastimento inglese
e ritrasmesso a Londra
e così Londra
viene a sapere
che gli argentini
hanno occupato
le isole Falkland
il governo inglese
si riunisce al buio
ma sapendo che ormai
la crisi è inevitabile
cosa fare?
la Thatcher
informa i suoi ministri
che ha già dato ordine
di radunare una flotta
e ormai la flotta
si sta radunando
bisognerà decidere
se farla partire
discutono a lungo
nel frattempo
discutono molte altre cose
esempio di dettaglio
che discute
il governo inglese
quel venerdì 2 aprile
la flotta sarà guidata
dalla portaerei
Invincible
ma sulla portaerei
è imbarcato come ufficiale
il principe Andrew
figlio della regina
che si fa
se la portaerei
salpa per la guerra
il principe Andrew
rimane al suo posto
o è meglio
tenerlo a casa?
discussione
fra Downing Street
Buckingham Palace
la regina esprime
il suo parere
il principe Andrew
finché è in servizio
sulla portaerei
Invincible
parteciperà
alla spedizione
suo nonno
il re Giorgio VI
ha combattuto
la battaglia
dello Jutland
e di conseguenza
è escluso
che un membro
della famiglia reale
possa essere trattato
diversamente
da qualunque altro ufficiale
sospiro di sollievo
risolto questo problema
la Thatcher
grosso modo
non vede più
altri grandi problemi
quella sera
il governo
decide che la flotta
parte
tra due giorni
appena pronta
la flotta
salperà
questo benché
il ministero degli esteri
stia facendo
un sacco di storie
nelle memorie
della Thatcher
si vede la sua
esasperazione
nei confronti
del ministero degli esteri
il quale dice
mi hanno fatto
tutta una serie
di osservazioni
dice la Thatcher
notate lo stile
Thatcher
che dimostravano
la flessibilità
di principi
caratteristica
di quel ministero
c'è un ministero
molle
perché pensa
è troppo
ecco
mi hanno parlato
dei rischi
per gli inglesi
che abitano in Argentina
del problema
di ottenere
il supporto
dell'ONU
la poca fiducia
nella comunità europea
negli Stati Uniti
il rischio
di un coinvolgimento
sovietico
il pericolo
di essere visti
dal mondo
come una potenza
coloniale
dice la Thatcher
tutte cose giuste
ma quando sei
in guerra
non puoi permettere
che le difficoltà
dominino
il tuo pensiero
devi andare avanti
con la volontà
di ferro
di superarle
e comunque
qual era
l'alternativa
che un dittatore
qualunque
un dittatore
da operetta
dovesse governare
i sudditi
della regina
e prevalere
con l'imbroglio
e la violenza
non finché
io ero
primo ministro
questo ben inteso
che questo è scritto dopo
ma insomma
comunque
l'idea della Thatcher
è sicuramente quella
il 2 aprile
quando gli argentini
sono già sbarcati
Reagan ci prova ancora
telefona a Galtieri
Galtieri risponde
l'Inghilterra
ha rifiutato
di restituire
le Folkland
per 149 anni
adesso il tempo
è scaduto
in Inghilterra
ricordiamoci
la Thatcher
è un primo ministro
in crisi
impopolare
considerato debole
che perderà
le prossime elezioni
quando i giornali
escono il 3 aprile
con la notizia
che gli argentini
hanno occupato
le Folkland
la sensazione
in Inghilterra
è di umiliazione
nazionale
c'è successo
un altro disastro
abbiamo fatto
un'altra figuraccia
i giornali dicono
la peggior umiliazione
per l'Inghilterra
dopo Suez
cos'è Suez
gli egiziani
nazionalizzano
il canale di Suez
che serve agli inglesi
gli inglesi
mandano i paracadutisti
per occupare il canale
gli americani
dicono agli inglesi
lasciate perdere
tornate a casa
e gli inglesi
tornano a casa
con la coda fra le gambe
nella memoria inglese
è il momento
in cui l'Inghilterra
scopre che non è più
una potenza mondiale
anzi
che rischia di essere
ridicola
quando cerca di intervenire
nel mondo
quel 3 aprile
dell'82
i giornali inglesi
dicono
è un'altra Suez
e quel giorno
la Thatcher
deve affrontare
il Parlamento
è sabato
è la prima volta
da molti decenni
che il Parlamento
inglese
è convocato
di sabato
la Camera dei Comuni
è strapiena
voi sapete
com'è la Camera dei Comuni
è piccola
non c'è un posto
per ogni deputato
tanto non ci sono mai
tutti
e quando vengono tutti
è perché è una cosa importante
ed è bene
che siano tutti lì affollati
in piedi
seduti sui gradini
ad ascoltare
quello che succede
l'altra caratteristica
del Parlamento inglese
che dobbiamo ricordare
perché noi siamo abituati
al nostro
il Parlamento inglese
è un Parlamento
dove molti deputati
votano come pensano loro
e non come dice il partito
è perfettamente normale
nel Parlamento inglese
che su questioni importanti
si coagulino
maggioranze
trasversali
e dunque
nel Parlamento inglese
è fondamentale
convincere
i deputati
per cui
quello è un Parlamento
dove saper fare
i discorsi
è una cosa
importantissima
la Thatcher
fa uno dei grandi discorsi
della sua carriera
dicendo al Parlamento
io credo che sarete
tutti d'accordo
a condannare
come me
questa aggressione
è un'aggressione
dice la Thatcher
che non ha
uno straccio
di giustificazione
e non ha
un briciolo
di legalità
Thatcher
prende in pugno
il Parlamento
c'è solo un momento
in cui rischia di perderlo
perché
vuole fare
una cattiveria
ai laburisti
vuole ricordare
all'opposizione
qualche debolezza
che loro hanno avuto
quando erano al governo
e allora comincia a dire
posso ricordare
agli onorevoli membri
dell'opposizione
che anche loro
anche loro
quando erano al governo
e un deputato
laburista
interrompe
noi non abbiamo
perso le Falkland
ecco in quel momento
traballa un po'
l'umore della Camera
ma la Thatcher
lo riprende in pugno
e alla fine
il Parlamento
vota
a favore
della partenza
della flotta
la flotta parte
sta per partire
il Parlamento
ha deciso
la Thatcher
nelle sue memorie
dice
io ero comunque
terrorizzata
perché la maggioranza
non c'era mica
in realtà
quella maggioranza
era finta
qualcuno come me
era disposto
ad andare avanti
fino alla guerra
molti pensavano
facciamo partire
la flotta
gli argentini
si spaventeranno
si comincia
a negoziare
andare fino in fondo
dice la Thatcher
lo pensavano
in pochi
e al contrario
c'è anche
nel Parlamento
chi dice
si si
adesso questa signora
fa bella figura
ma avrà
poi il fegato
questa donna
di andare
fino in fondo
c'è un intervento
che in Inghilterra
è rimasto famoso
ve lo racconto
tanto siamo qui
per raccontare cose
quindi ve lo racconto
un deputato
si chiama
Enoch Powell
è un politico
famosissimo
in Inghilterra
popolarissimo
è una specie
di freelance
è uno di destra
un conservatore
però ha mollato
i conservatori
sta per conto suo
è uno che ha
le sue posizioni
è molto contro
immigrati
per esempio
molto nazionalista
ma su altre cose
è invece di sinistra
è un personaggio
molto bizzarro
Enoch Powell
interviene
quel 3 aprile
alla Camera dei Comuni
e
la Thatcher
si ricorda
che intervenendo
la guardava
fisso
e che interviene
dice in tono
sepolcrale
e in tono
Enoch Powell
dice
il primo ministro
poco dopo
essere andata
al potere
è stata
soprannominata
la Lady
di Ferro
perché questo
soprannome
la Thatcher
l'aveva avuto
subito
erano i sovietici
che l'avevano
soprannominata così
vedendo il tipo
tosto che era
questo soprannome
dice il deputato
Powell
è nato
nel contesto
dei rapporti
con l'Unione
Sovietica
e i suoi alleati
ma c'è motivo
di pensare
che l'onorevole
Lady
sia stata
molto soddisfatta
e anzi
inorgoglita
di questo
soprannome
nella prossima
settimana
o due
questa
Camera
la nazione
e la stessa
onorevole
Lady
apprenderanno
di che metallo
è fatta
ecco
la Thatcher
lascia il Parlamento
con questo
augurio
e questa
aspettativa
vedremo
di che metallo
sei fatta
va detto
che la Thatcher
sa di essere
in sintonia
con il Paese
il Paese
più
del Parlamento
più del Ministero
degli Esteri
è deciso
ad andare
fino in fondo
ci sono i sondaggi
i sondaggi
sono chiarissimi
l'ottanta per cento
degli inglesi
risponde
che bisogna
riprendersi
le Falkland
poi la seconda
domanda è
ma è meglio
riprenderle
con un negoziato
pacifico
o con la forza
la maggioranza
degli inglesi
risponde
con la forza
dunque la Thatcher
è in sintonia
con il suo popolo
la flotta
partirà
a questo punto
qualcuno
comincia a dire
ma
è una guerra
dichiariamo
guerra
c'è una riunione
noi abbiamo
questi documenti
bellissimi
che vi dicevo
verbale
del comitato
dei deputati
conservatori
online
c'è la trascrizione
c'è anche il verbale
originale
a penna
con i disegnini
le sottolineature
e i deputati
uno dopo l'altro
dicono di tutto
c'è anche
Lord Onslow
il cui intervento è
affondiamogli
tutta la flotta
ma la maggior parte
dei deputati
ecco qualche deputato
è preoccupato
c'è un deputato
che dice
la gente è preoccupata
per questa cosa
che è successa
e non bisogna
farci vedere
molli
il ministero
degli esteri
in questo momento
puzza
puzza di
appeasement
ricordate
chi c'era di voi
ieri
l'appeasement
cos'è
è il nome
che nella politica
inglese si dà
al tentativo
di Chamberlain
nel 38
di tenere buono
Hitler
concedendogli
tante cose
l'appeasement
la pace a tutti i costi
nell'essico politico
inglese
è diventata
una parolaccia
in quel momento
nell'82
c'è chi dice
ma insomma
il ministero degli esteri
continua a dire
trattiamo
è pericoloso
questo puzza
di appeasement
andiamo avanti
però poi
la maggior parte
dei deputati
dicono
siamo in guerra
il ministro degli esteri
Lord Carrington
risponde
no
non c'è obbligo
di dichiarare guerra
non siamo in guerra
altri deputati
insistono
ma dichiarate guerra
Lord Carrington
è difficile
dichiarare guerra
ci sono
delle difficoltà
allegali
dobbiamo sentire
gli avvocati
e questo sta
verbale
in realtà
questo copre
il fatto
che il governo
ha deciso
che dichiarare guerra
sarebbe una complicazione
inutile
questi sono
veramente
i tempi nuovi
perché gli uomini
del 14
e perfino
quelli del 39
si preoccupavano
di mandare
l'ambasciatore
con la dichiarazione
di guerra
magari piena di bugie
ma la mandavano
invece
adesso i tempi
sono cambiati
adesso
sono tempi
forse più cinici
o più pragmatici
anche un po' più furbi
forse tutto sommato
va a sapere
tutto questo insieme
ma la guerra
non c'è nessun motivo
di dichiararla
lo ribadisce ufficialmente
la signora Thatcher
due giorni dopo
il 5 aprile
intervista
alla signora Thatcher
il giornalista
ma
sta davvero
per fare la guerra
all'argentina
Thatcher
il nostro obiettivo
è recuperare
le isole
Falkland
dobbiamo fare
quello che è necessario
per riuscirci
io non parlerei
in termini di guerra
una dichiarazione di guerra
è qualcosa di diverso
non entriamo
nei dettagli tecnici
noi dobbiamo
recuperare
le isole Falkland
per la Gran Bretagna
e per la gente
che ci vive
non diciamo
che è guerra
non lo è
una dichiarazione di guerra
è tecnicamente diversa
sto sempre citando
alla lettera
e dall'intervista
non insistete
sugli aspetti tecnici
sappiamo cosa dobbiamo fare
ci sono molti modi diversi
di ottenerlo
speriamo di non aver scelto
il peggiore
quando fermi un dittatore
ci sono sempre dei rischi
ma ci sono molti grandi rischi
a non fermare i dittatori
la mia generazione
lo ha imparato
tanto tempo fa
e qui naturalmente
noi dobbiamo riflettere
su questo aspetto
le generazioni
la Thatcher
l'abbiamo conosciuta tutti
ma adesso è morta
ed era molto vecchia
la Thatcher ha vissuto
la seconda guerra
l'appeasement
e Hitler
e la seconda guerra mondiale
e per lei
nell'82
erano comunque cose
che aveva vissuto
che ricordava bene
e quindi
l'influenza
di quello che era successo
nel 39
interviene nell'82
cosa deve fare
l'Inghilterra
davanti al dittatore
cercare di fermarlo
e uscirne con la vergogna
come a Monaco
cioè non cercare di fermarlo
deve fermarlo
il ministero degli esteri
lo sapete
non era d'accordo
e infatti
il 5 aprile
Lord Carrington
si dimette
dichiarando
era il mio ministero
che doveva gestire
questa crisi
non ci siamo riusciti
siamo alla guerra
io sul mio onore
sento che devo dimettermi
ora Lord Carrington
era un caro amico
della signora Thatcher
un fedele collaboratore
ma la politica
è quello che è
adesso vi dico
la reazione
della signora Thatcher
quando la intervistano
al fatto che il suo ministro
degli esteri
Peter Carrington
si è dimesso
la signora Thatcher
dice
è stato un grave colpo
per me
mi dispiace molto
perderlo
era un uomo prezioso
per il mio governo
ma cosa farci
lui sentiva
ha sentito
di essere responsabile
che il suo ministero
era responsabile
della gestione
della crisi
la gestione è fallita
e perciò lui ha sentito
che era una questione
di onore
andarsene
a me dispiace molto
e poi dice la Thatcher
però sapete
è proprio meraviglioso
avere in politica
delle persone
che sentono così tanto
l'onore
e che quando è il momento
si dimettono
e quindi
exit Lord Carrington
oh è quasi finito eh
io non vi racconto
la guerra
vi racconto solo
com'è che Margaret
ha deciso
di far partire la flotta
poi per un mese
gli americani
cercheranno di farla
spola
con gli argentini
e con gli inglesi
dicendo fermatevi
tutti stanno fermi
sulle loro posizioni
e la guerra si arriva
però in Argentina
ben prima che si arrivi
allo sbarco inglese
e alla guerra
in Argentina
il morale crolla
la stampa argentina
continua a dire
siamo pronti
li aspettiamo
ma
specialmente ad alto livello
nella società argentina
serpeggia il panico
noi abbiamo
un rapporto segreto
dei servizi segreti
americani
testimonianza
di un politico
argentino
di alto livello
che è stato membro
della giunta militare
che appoggia
la giunta militare
e che al suo
confidente
americano dice
questo politico
argentino
ormai
o la va o la spacca
cioè se alla fine
teniamo le folkland
bene
se no Galtieri
cade
non possiamo
metterci a negoziare
adesso
sarebbe peggio
Galtieri
cadrebbe subito
per lui
semmai è meglio
perdere la guerra
e
l'osservatore americano
annota
in ogni caso
il mio interlocutore
argentino
è sicuro
che l'argentina
perderà
non c'è nessun
politico
nel paese
che non pensi
che l'invasione
è stata
un colossale
errore
c'è la consapevolezza
che il presidente
e i suoi consiglieri
sono degli incompetenti
e poi c'è questa cosa
che io essendo un italiano
ho trovato affascinante
il politico
argentino
dice all'americano
ci ha detto
che lui ormai
ha 41 anni
e che adesso
sa che
nell'arco
della sua vita
non vedrà mai
un'argentina
seria
il bello
è che l'americano
non capisce
cosa vuol dire
spiega
intende dire
un paese stabile
democratico
e prospero
ma io come italiano
capisco benissimo
cosa penso
l'argentino
quando dice
ma perché il mio paese
non è serio
lo vedrò mai
un paese serio
dice no
questo argentino
forse i miei figli
vedranno un paese
un'argentina seria
io ho capito
che non la vedrò più
infatti
la guerra
finisce
come sapete
in poche settimane
gli inglesi
vincono
stravincono
la guerra
costa
mille morti
argentini
inglesi
tre civili
delle folkled
la guerra
mai dichiarata
e quindi
non c'è neanche bisogno
di fare un trattato
di pace
è stata una cosa
è successa
ma non è dichiarata
non lascia traccia
ha delle belle conseguenze
il 14 giugno
la bandiera argentina
viene abbassata
su port stanley
e le ultime truppe
argentine
si arrendono
quattro giorni
il 18 giugno
Galtieri
si dimette
mandano un altro generale
tentano di tenere in piedi
la dittatura
non ce la fanno
la situazione è tale
che la giunta militare
è costretta
a convocare
libera elezione
ricordate
Alfonsin
che diventa presidente
dell'argentina
finisce la dittatura militare
Galtieri
sarà in prigione
dall'86 al 91
poi è graziato
poi lo rimettono
sotto processo
nel 2002
gli viene un infarto
e poi morto
agli arresti domiciliari
come capita
con i politici anziani
che vengono messi
sotto accusa
quando muore Galtieri
nel 2003
l'Economist
scrive
quel necrologio
che vi ho già citato
all'inizio
perfido
in cui fra l'altro
dice
Galtieri
forse qualcuno
dei suoi compatrioti
poteva perdonarlo
per la sua spietatezza
ma non
per la sua stupidità
quindi la guerra
delle Falkland
fa cadere
la giunta militare
argentina
e crea
la signora Thatcher
perché la svolta
nella carriera politica
di Margaret Thatcher
è la guerra
delle Falkland
all'indomani
la Thatcher
è il politico
più forte
che ci sia mai stato
nel Regno Unito
da tanto tempo
stravince
le elezioni
dell'83
e fa
tutto quello che fa
per il bene
o per il male
a seconda di come
ognuno di noi
pensa
quel deputato
Enoch Powell
che era intervenuto
in Parlamento
dicendo
nelle prossime settimane
il paese vedrà
di che metallo
è fatto
il primo ministro
voi sapete
come sono gli inglesi
e come funziona
il loro Parlamento
in una successiva seduta
dopo la fine della guerra
il deputato Powell
prende la parola
e dichiara
ci vorrei far sapere
al primo ministro
che ho qui
ho il rapporto
di un istituto
di analisi
su una certa sostanza
della cui composizione
si era discusso
e risulta
che quella sostanza
di cui si parlava
è ferro
della miglior qualità
resistentissimo
alle tensioni
adatto a ogni impiego
nell'interesse
del paese
e la signora Thatcher
diventa appunto
la signora Thatcher
e poche settimane dopo
in un discorso ufficiale
dice questa cosa
quello che mi ha
elettrizzata davvero
dopo aver passato
tanta della mia vita
in Parlamento
a discutere di cose
come l'inflazione
gli assegni familiari
il problema degli alloggi
i problemi dell'ambiente
e così via
e che quando è venuto
il momento della prova
quello che ha elettrizzato
la gente
non erano quelle cose lì
quello che ha elettrizzato
la gente
era il fatto
di poter di nuovo
servire
una grande causa
la causa
della libertà
ecco
forse sarebbe stata
più sincera
se avesse detto
quello che ha eccitato
la gente
è stato trovarsi di nuovo
a fare la guerra
però
ha avuto anche
un modo di metterla
che insomma
dalle torto poi
servire la causa
della libertà
ecco
come tante cose
di Margaret Thatcher
questa dichiarazione
e in generale
la sua gestione
della crisi
delle Folkland
può entusiasmare
qualcuno
o può far venire
i brividi
a qualcun altro
o magari tutte e due
le cose insieme
che in fondo
è l'effetto
che ha fatto a me
ecco
così come andare
a rivedere
in queste tre serate
com'è che scoppiano
le guerre
come dire
a me ha insegnato
tante cose
mi ha anche
elettrizzato
appassionato
mi ha anche messo
un po' di brividi
vedendo com'è che
scoppiano le guerre
com'è che i politici
gestiscono le crisi
e spero che sia successo
così anche a voi
grazie e all'anno prossimo
grazie
arrivederci